c'est une balade en haute-saône que je
vous propose aujourd'hui danse et là
certains ont choisi la vitesse est terre
de la faire vivre
l'occasion pour eux de se réinventer
parfois même changer de nom avec une
envie donner du sens à leur travail et à
leur territoire des héros des temps
modernes nous ferez votre idée un
regardez c'est là on l'a dit rurales
reculées
certains diront même qu'elle est
déconnecté pourtant derrière le cliché
la haute-saône regorge d'acteurs qu'il
en fait évolué et qui la transforme au
quotidien ils ont fait le pari de vivre
ici et de faire vivre leur territoire
sur la route de lancre en quittant
vesoul
nous plongeons dans cette haute saône
rurales et populaires
un peu à l'écart des sentiers battus
certains sont arrivés là par hasard
d'autres aux grandes ici sur ses terres
agricoles en plein doute
ils sont devenus paysan boulanger
éleveurs truffiers brasseur et cherche à
donner du sens à leur métier à leur
territoire à leur vie dans une époque où
les campagnes sont souvent loin de tout
mais sans pour autant vivre qu'on
retirait du monde
toussaint et danses et chants
en ce début d'hiver ils ne sont pas hors
aux pauvres les graines plantées il ya
quelques semaines commencent à sortir de
terre
blanc de la sones blanc du morvan ou
rouges de bordeaux
ces céréales sont des variétés anciennes
qui fourniront la farine dont il fait
son pain tout s'inscrivant boulanger
faire du bon bah il faut à la base un
bon blé du blick a du goût donc j'ai
voulu maîtriser la filière complète on
peut dire ça permet de ne pas passer par
des intermédiaires quand on est
agriculteur d'habitude on fait pousser
et après on s'occupe plus de rien on
amène la récolte à des grossistes et un
s'occupe de la revendre à d'autres qui
vont à transformer qui vont la revendre
à d'autres qui vont encore faire du
parec elle a du coup chacun prend sa
part et il n'y a plus rien pour
l'agriculteur qu'a fait pousser la base
le blé sylvie sa mère est associée à
l'exploitation elle est dedans c'est
après midi de façonnage la ferme est
dans la famille depuis quatre
générations
ses parents faisait du lait tout ça lui
a décidé d'utiliser les céréales de la
ferme pour faire de la farine et le pain
il souhaite maîtriser toute la chaîne de
fabrication
il a construit lui-même son four à pain
avec un ami
prix et les graines il a récupéré une
vieille trieuse manuel sur laquelle il a
greffé un moteur de machines à laver et
puis il s'est équipé de ce petit moulin
chaque année et produits à la ferme sept
tonnes de farine temps à beaucoup de
compagnies une trentaine malgrave
compléter le four on sent quand même que
de blé pain dans ses murs il ya toujours
ce problème bien quand on dit qu'il faut
pas l'utiliser avant noël ou encore tout
comme un peu trop court et il faut
l'apprivoiser eastpak el eulma était
bien une dame est joli but que je vais
partir
ici tout est produit en bio ce qui
impose d'être très attentif à sharon et
la farine n'est pas standardisés c'est
une matière vivante
tous ces gestes tout ça a dû les
apprendre pour lui reprendre la ferme
était tout sauf une évidence il a fait
l'école hôtelière puis est parti
travailler plusieurs années au canada
et puis un jour sylvie a reçu une bonne
nouvelle
son fils avait choisi de retrouver le
travail de la terre
quand un jour par skype ça fait drôle on
à son fils sur l'écran qui dit bassili à
une place sur la ferme pour moi est ce
que je peux revenir à des milliers de
kilomètres ouah bah ouais je crois qu'on
peut dire que c'était pas paysan père en
fils non il n'était pas à prédéterminé
du tout à l'agriculture il a redécouvert
en fait
l'importance de la terre pendant neuf
mois
tout ça est retourné à l'école il a
appris à moudre à pétrir à façonner et à
faire cuire le pain de sa ferme
ils étaient paysans il est aussi devenu
boulanger
c'était surtout un grand dynamisme sur
la ferme
nous on arrivait un peu à la
cinquantaine bon voilà
on s'use on fatigue on est dans le train
train c'était une envie de donner du
sens aux et mon activité de paysan
boulanger il y avait plus de commerces
au village depuis depuis plus de 50 ans
on a perdu un tiers de sa population
entre la fin du 19e et l'aube des trente
glorieuses durement touchée par l'exode
rural l'agriculture a été confronté à la
concentration des exploitations dans les
cinq enfants dans la maison
et puis c'est toi le seul qui a décidé
de rester pour quoi ouais je me plais
ici il faut produire plus pas forcément
mieux avec moins de paysans à l'image de
ce qui s'est passé dans le reste du pays
c'est sûrement aussi de défi relevé par
tous à défendre une agriculture à taille
humaine qui prend en compte
l'environnement et celles qui en juillet
monuments symbolisant la mort on
producteurs laitiers de la région
[Musique]
pourtant ce département malgré sa
réputation agricole a connu une
industrialisation précoce est importante
les new year de ronchamp les fabriques
textile les usines peugeot c'est tout un
maillage industriel qui a souffert de la
crise et qui continuent à souffrir
aujourd'hui l'accord est bu trop de
temps et il ya eu de commerce côtoyer
tous les boucheries tout ce qui est
fermé
y'a plus rien khairi tout à fait unique
n'a plus rien
[Musique]
le plancher parents chose à faire c'est
de services minitel de la région
aujourd'hui avec son clocher comtois à
l'impérial la vigne est un petit village
typique de la haute saône le tissu
économique y est resté très vivant on y
trouve encore une coopérative laitière
des paysans évidemment et un brasseur
alexandre est un enfant du pays il est
parti vivre à paris puis à la rochelle
un jour avec sa compagne il a décidé de
rentrer au village pour monter sa propre
micro hybrid sa mère et jean habite à
deux pas elle est venue l'aider pour
l'embouteillage commence et mamie petite
gamelle c'était vraiment pas buvable au
début on a tout jeté puis fur et à
mesure des essais c'était de plus en
plus buvable puis voilà il ya un moment
donné où effectivement c'était plutôt
bon quand j'ai démarré j'ai quand même
bénéficié aussi d'un climat dans les
lacs qui était déjà assez fort déjà de
l'image du patelin et puis et ben en
fait voilà une coop après il ya un
brasseur après ça appelle aussi des
activités en fait voilà quand les gens
cherchent des choses où s'installer ou à
faire des choses bien c'est un argument
en plus quoi fin il ya des gens qui sont
là
[Applaudissements]
oui à l'aube et l'aisne
moi j'ai un petit soucis je dois livrer
à charcenne les bières de noël pour
qu'elle parte à paris j'emmène pas mal
de cartons j'aurais vraiment besoin du
camion ouais je vais venir maintenant
les déchets du brassage ne sont
évidemment pas jetés ils repartent comme
dans une économie circulaire pour
produire mieux en réduisant les impacts
et serviront à nourrir les cochons
c'est ce que voulait alexandre faire
vivre son village en développant son
activité aussi chez lui avoir du temps
pour ses enfants et surtout que la vigne
et ne se transforme pas en cité dortoir
on a tous compris que de toute façon
l'activité de l'un des points mais aussi
de l'activité de l'autre quoi ça veut
dire que on n'a pas du tout intérêt
qu'il y en ait un qui se casse la figure
à côté de nous à côté dans ce village et
qu'on a plutôt intérêt à s'entraider
quoi non plus il ya des choses qui
peuvent être mutualisés car plus ça va
continuer ses quatre activités la cua
super tu peux me prendre mes carottes à
port sur saône au fil des choses qui
restent et qui permettent à chacun de
mutualiser les coûts et de mieux vivre
le quotidien puis d'assouplir un peu la
fnil chose
[Musique]
hélène et la maraîchère de la vigne et
s'est installé sur cette pâture à vaches
il y a 6 ans avec mari et enfants en
partant de rien ou presque pour créer
son exploitation qu'elle a tout
simplement appeler les jardins d'hélène
je suis plutôt de milieu urbain enfin
j'ai grandi en ville mais j'ai fait des
études d'aménagement du territoire avec
une spécialité sur le milieu rural
j'étais attiré par par ce qui s'y
passait par la vie des gens par
l'agriculture bio aussi j'ai découvert
ce monde là en haute saône
et puis bah j'ai fait le choix quand
j'ai eu mes enfants bas de changer de
métier changer de vie parce que je les
voyais pas grandir et j'avais envie en
même temps que de me lancer dans
l'agriculture aussi bas avoir une autre
vie de famille donc c'est ça qui m'a
motivé à faire une formation agricole
puisque j'avais quand même pas beaucoup
de base j'ai jamais vu mes parents
jardiner avant de s'installer et après
sa formation de neuf mois elle n a
travaillé durant trois ans chez d'autres
maraîchers de la région pour continuer à
apprendre son métier est exigeant
les variétés et les techniques sont très
nombreuses en maraîchage surtout en bio
il faut savoir tout anticipé dans le
soin des fruits et des légumes
moi j'ai choisi de faire pousser des
légumes qui nous permette à la fois de
manger nous donc pour la famille et de
vendre à des gens qui qui avec avait pas
de jardin qui avait besoin de légumes
pour la semaine donc c'est très
diversifié il ya de tout fin selon les
saisons
on cultive
soixantaine de variétés de légumes qui
sont proposés chaque semaine à la vente
c'est pas un métier facile parce que
c'est très physique dans tous les
métiers agricoles
c'est presque le plus physique parce
qu'on fait beaucoup de choses à la main
on est quand même souvent baissé pour
pour récolter pour biner pour entretenir
mais je crois que quand on a choisi ce
sa voix et son métier ça passe mieux
quoi
quand hélène et sa famille se sont
installés à la viny et souhaitait avant
tout construire un projet cohérent entre
la vie de famille le travail et leur
lieu de vie une nouvelle étape dans leur
installation en haute saône
hélène vend sa production directement
ici mais aussi dans d'autres petits
points de vente dans la région
oui ouais bah écoutes je suis en train
de changer de faire un panier pour
stéphane donc si tu veux c'est parfois
ils sont sortis salut bonjour quand même
moi je ne serai pas installer maraîchère
bio s'il n'y avait pas eu tout ce réseau
autour humainement c'est ça qui
maintient la motivation aussi parce
qu'on se retrouve le vendredi soir sur
le petit marché on est on est cinq six à
avoir les mêmes réalités pas les mêmes
activités mais les mêmes réalités de se
lever tôt le matin de dépendre du temps
du temps qui fait par rapport à nos
productions
oui c'est pour l'hiver là je les met
sous les sons qu'on échange beaucoup et
ça se fait à la fois avec des gens qui
sont du coin et qui sont passés en bio
depuis très longtemps
puis à la fois aux nouveaux arrivés
comme moi des gens qui sont pas d'ici et
on arrive vraiment à créer un réseau
intéressant à nous tous avec des
tranches d'âge différentes et ça se
passe bien et c'est vraiment chouette ou
et
série magic on pourra parler calendrier
du coup ce changement de vie a été
rendue possible aussi parce qu'ils
étaient deux à la maison avec leurs
enfants et le salaire des rixes sont
marie laure a été très utile le temps
que l'exploitation des laines fonctionne
quand on a dit il ya six ans c'était une
pâture à vaches dans un premier temps on
a on s'est consacré surtout à
l'installation du maraîchage puisque
c'était l'urgence que moi je puisse
démarrer mon activité
et puis un an après on a commencé la
construction de la maison surtout de
retaper le hangar dans un premier temps
parce qu'il était vraiment à l'abandon
quoi avec des tôles de partout et on a
regardé deux boîtes ou le hangar avant
de construire la maison dessous donc on
a construit une maison en paille pour
habiter sur place c'est quand même plus
pratique quand on a ce genre d'activités
leur bâtisse ne ressemble à aucune autre
du bois de la paille delachaux à la fois
entrepôt agricole et maison de famille
c'est un endroit qui leur ressemble
sur les coteaux de noroît les us et
quelques kilomètres plus au nord
pousse une truffière ici il ya une
quinzaine d'années ont été plantés des
chaînes et des noisetiers pour créer cet
endroit idéal dédié à la culture des
truffes tous que
jean avec sa compagne nadine avait fait
ce rêve transformé ce qui n'était qu'un
champ de maïs en paradis de la truffe de
bourgogne en ce tout début d'hiver nous
sommes en haute saison des champignons
noirs sont arrivés à maturité et comme
chaque week-end il organise à travers
leur association des ateliers des
commerces en fête 2004 a mis un peu
toutes les essences
mais passer par le ch ne me succès
s'enchaînent particulier c'est parce que
la truffe
comme tout champignons elles par des
sous afin de les racines woody au départ
même vers le tronc way plus les racines
que se développent plus la truffe on la
retrouve sur l'extérieur pour m on peut
en trouver là on peut lui demander d'y
aller le chercher un peu tu cherches
allez allez on cherche à des avis de
recherche
allez tu cherches chercheurs tchèques
allez c'est bien coupe c'est bien
on va chercher à l'est
eh bien oui c'est bien des biens du
shérif
[Musique]
alors voilà cocotte la y avoir des
regards je regarde c'est moi qui aurais
elle ne mangerai pas si je regarde j'ai
vu un petit ogre maintenant un gros du
tout mais d'ivoire
elle mit au monde et est dépassée à la
il ya peut-être une foule
je regarde pas il regarde c'est bien
elle est là et là avant même la
plantation les racines des arbres ont
opté imbibé de mycélium de cloche c'est
ainsi que le champignon peut doucement
se développer au fil des saisons
c'est quoi le climat qu'il faut alors
pour avoir une bonne bonne production
bonne récolte printemps on va dire bruit
enfin comme cette année mais les ptt
beaucoup de précipitations au printemps
c'est là où elles se forment
puis des précipitations en été sérénité
qu'elle se développe
cette année les truffes sont là par
contre sont moins grosse que prévu
d'accor du fait qu'il ya eu un peu moins
d'eau en été avec ça sent quand tu l'as
en bouche quoi pas mal ouais mais on
retrouve quand même le ce que tu as en
bouche de petite odeur
pour nadine et jean une chasse aux
truffes doit toujours se compléter par
un moment de dégustation
cette truffe de bourgogne dit la
princesse du bar war pour le joyau des
bois était largement répandue dans tout
l'est de la france elle était la seule
truffe à figurer sur des tables royales
jusqu'à la renaissance avant d'être
durement concurrencée par la truffe du
périgord que françois 1er leur préférera
elle a fini par complètement tombé dans
l'oubli au 20e siècle
mais depuis une vingtaine d'années grâce
à cette technique de plants truffiers
que pratique chant et nadine la
production a été relancée
c'est un travail qui s'inscrit dans le
temps long il aura fallu attendre six
ans après la plantation avant de pouvoir
récolter les premières truffes oui c'est
très dur c'est très doux et de petits
barons à la merci je veux pas venir
faire table d'autres chez moi j'ai passé
moins raffiné la saisir mais bon très
bonne il faut pas du tout avoir peur de
la cuisine et il faut donc surtout la
mettre en contact avec un corps gras
toujours la veille pour le lendemain et
ensuite ce qui est important il ne faut
pas la montée à plus de 60 degrés au
niveau des températures on n'a pas une
culture truffes dans cette région par
contre dans les années 1880 ont récolté
40 tonnes de truffes aux zones où le
savoir
et ses truffes là elle est allée à paris
c'était pas la truffe du périgord
c'était notre rêve qui oui oui oui
déjà le transport de la truffe pour
aller à paris c'était beaucoup plus
court que sarlat impérieux et on
connaissait sur paris qu'un autre trèfle
à truffe de bourgogne mais on a perdu
cette tradition on a perdu 7
cette culture truffe donc on voudrait
essayer de la faire ressortir de pour ça
qu'on veut partager aussi ce que l'on
aime c'est important c'est important
dans ce canton
ils ne sont que 18 habitants kilomètres
carrés est nécessairement pour ses hauts
saônois
des liens se sont tissés au fil du temps
qui les ont rendus plus forts et moins
vulnérable aux sportifs ils partagent un
peu plus que le travail et ils savent
aussi accueillir et devenir une plate à
ceux qui choisissent de s'installer
russie à bernois sûrement ce sont
élevées des escargots qu'on appelle des
gros gris un élevage artisanale à leur
tête un couple chris christie ils sont
félicite ultor en cette saison les
escargots ont tous ses tirs et côté pour
préparer les fêtes de fin d'année dans
l'atelier ils sont en plein rush pour
noël du congé christine l on ne passera
pas par l'atelier cet après midi elle va
ouvrir lesca bar un petit bistrot qu'ils
ont fournies sur la place du village
ils ont rénové cette vieille bâtisse et
garder le chat qui habitait serbie ils
l'ont surnommé pablo pablo escobar 5,6
kg on n'achète rien ça fait pas trop de
l'autre que les étrangers fait des
escales au monde élu à la tête et aux
amis
il ya déjà beaucoup d'éleveurs des
escargots n'est pas pour beaucoup son
siècle et c'est encore les étrangers qui
faisaient pour les français en plus en
plus il aime ça alors qu'ils auraient
envie d'arriver ici c'est pas compliqué
dans le temps on chez c'est une maison
pour les vacances
on a cherché partout nous sommes arrivés
ici
christine tout de suite et ayant mieux
de la région de la maison donc qu'on a
on a payé l'addition pour espérer c mais
c'était pas évident pour rester ici tu
dois faire quelque chose pour camille
travail et donc j'étais informaticiens
avec les ordinateurs les situe ici puis
fait pour être pas grand chose
christine et et géomètres donc on a
pensé à plusieurs sauts à chose on a
suivi formation nous sommes lancés comme
ça et nous sommes restés ici on a changé
de vie un métier et on a plus de la
qualité de vie et c'est oui c'est un peu
mieux qu'un but et si tu peux vivre
normalement comme tu es pas comme une
autre personne dit oui peut cacher un
peu son coin perdu ici c'est bien
il fallait adapter du monde les
[Musique]
escalades proches que de folie mais je
me dis mais comment une fois qu'ils sont
pubiés nettoyer on met dans une courbe
lions et après on fait la face à
épaissir le reste on dépend
[Musique]
ils n'ont peut-être pas reculer la vie
rêvée des campagnes tel produit majine
de nos jours comme dans un paradis perdu
cette campagne n'existe plus ils sont au
contraire bien dans leur époque bien
dans leur temps on espère en je sais pas
si on y arrivera aussi être un peu des
moteurs pour permettre aux gens d'avoir
envie de créer quelque chose quoi qu'ils
disent que c'est possible et que qui
seront pas tout seul parce qu'on est
dans un endroit qui est qui est très peu
peuplée que qu'on est tout seul et au
contraire il ya même si on n'est pas
beaucoup on va serrer les coudes
on va essayer de l'avancer l'ensemble
c'est l'époque où on vit qui est qui qui
aussi oblique nous oblige aussi à
recréer les choses quoi et c'est
finalement la banque on est plutôt
inventeur quoi ces compteurs et des
restrictions qu'on réinvente des choses
quoi ses parents vivent dans l'opulence
qu'on en arrive à être dépassés c'est
plutôt en disant voilà combien des
contraintes on va on va réinventer quoi
ils sont conscients de leur fragilité de
leur force c'est la mettre en commun
celles qui restent à construire et des
solidarités a retrouvé c'est sûrement
aussi un peu ça la vie aujourd'hui en
dessous
[Musique]
je ne sais pas vous mais moi je dis
chapeau
allez donc les voir au détour d'une
balade a laissé là c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui
restons connectés sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ici la semaine prochaine
prenez soin de vous et puis non je vous
embrasse